[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous
nouvelle formule de 5 à 10 à l'occasion
des municipales nous allons recevoir
bertrand carruggi mois en alternance les
candidats aux élections de 2020 chaque
candidat aura sept minutes pour
s'exprimer ce matin nous recevons lionel
des roses bonjour bonjour bonjour aux
auditeurs de la martinique 1ère vous
êtes candidat à cette marie qu'est ce
qui vous pousse qu'est ce qui vous
motive alors ma motivation c'est quoi
c'est de voir la situation de ma ville
une ville qui m'est très cher une ville
qui se meurt qui n'a plus de boucles la
situation économique des des commerçants
du centre du centre bourg je me demande
comment ils font pour tenir il faut
redémarrer redynamiser le bourg la la
fracture sociale me perdre le coeur de
voir autant de jeunes désoeuvrés
alors comme beaucoup de politiques à
cette marie entend des choses vous
enlevez les jeunes des abribus et bien
nous n'avons nous avons la bonne volonté
de tout mettre en place pour éviter
qu'ils aillent dans les abribus d'autres
candidats disent que cette marie des
étangs cahier qu'il faut désenclaver
cette marie alors pour des incas et sept
maris la première chose à faire c'est de
réconcilier le peuple samaritain bon il
est impossible alors j'entends le
meilleur autant dire jouer à l'étonné
quand on parle de souffrance au niveau
du personnel municipal
mais nous avons des preuves ou
personnellement j'ai des preuves des
agents qui se sont retrouvés en
hospitalisés en service psychiatrique
parce que ils ont ils subissent la
souffrance au travail donc il y avait un
véritable une véritable ségrégation une
vide envie d'un problème ne serait ce
que déjà au niveau du conseil municipal
il va falloir réconcilier l'opérationnel
et réconcilier l'ensemble des
samaritains ce qui permet le permettra
de travailler dans de meilleures
conditions pour les contribuables
samaritain pour pouvoir décoder un
cahier cette maille
on dit que vous y allez le nail des
roses à reculons que vous n'avez pas
vraiment envie d'y aller cette année je
vais en réfléchissant
il ne s'agit pas d'aller pour aller il
s'agit de prendre le temps pendant que
les autres fanfaronne lionel des roses
parcours les quartiers échanges dans des
dents dans des réunions de quartier avec
la population pour établir un programme
pour la population nous rencontrons la
population quasiment deux fois par
semaine afin d'entendre leurs doléances
et de voir dans toutes leurs demandes de
toutes leurs attentes
ce qu'il est possible de faire ce que
les possibles de leur proposer ce que ce
qui est aussi dit c'est que me lionel de
rose aurait préféré peut-être aller en
créant l'unité sur une liste d'union
avec d'autres candidats que dalle créer
sa propre liste pour aller dans une dans
une autre élection m criait vraiment une
autre une liste d'union avec d'autres
candidats alors lionel des roses n'est
pas denis mer
ma volonté c'est pas à tout prix d'être
mère mais c'est de partager le travail
pour permettre le billet net des
samaritains avec des personnes qui
partagent c'est un homme de valeur on
nous a rapporté que vous avez pris des
contacts avec jeu avec cette ivres ont
tout à fait j'ai rencontré les synthés
voudront nous avons discuté et il se
trouve que nous avons choisi d'aller au
premier tout chacun de notre bord pour
différentes raisons
d'accord et postiga deuxième tour vous
pourriez vous retrouver alors à l'autre
est probablement ce qui nous rapproche
est bien plus grand que ce qui nous
sépare maintenant il va falloir que
chacun fasse les concessions nécessaires
et
en tout cas en tout cas il faut compter
une alternative à la ville de sète mari
et on mettra tout en place pour que
cette alternative arrive alors quels
sont les grands axes que vous allez
développer dans votre campagne vous
allez pas vous avez parlé du centre
bourg mais encore alors le social c'est
vraiment le cheval de bataille
il faut aller au coeur du problème
il faut arrêter de faire du saupoudrage
par le biais du ccas pour tenter
d'enlever les jeunes au coin de rue dans
les escaliers des immeubles il faut
mettre en place un véritable plan
marshall pour permettre aux jeunes de ne
pas se retrouver dans les abribus les
enlever c'est déjà beaucoup plus
difficile il faut les enlever ceux qui
sont déjà là mais il faut empêcher que
d'autres yayi et ça nous comptons passer
par le biais des associations un
véritable levier pour combattre la
fracture sociale
il faut accompagner les associations de
cette marie financièrement admise est
administrativement parce qu'il faut pas
oublier que ce sont des bénévoles en
quelle association aujourd'hui peut
prendre en charge sa jeunesse à part
leur montrer le mercredi après midi
comme on joue au football hommage aux
ondes qu'elle a ce qu'est l'association
de cette marie met en place un
accompagnement social pour les familles
des licenciés
ça n'existe pas ce sera notre dada
empêcher aux jeunes de dérivés empêcher
aux familles de s'éclater lunel des
roses je vous remercie
bonne journée à l'écouté de nos
programmes c'est moi qui vous remercie